[MUSIC PLAYING]
INES ENVID: Good
morning, everyone.
Thank you for being here.
It is a pleasure to share
this conference with you.
We're going to be
talking today about how
you think about
security, securing
the access to your
to your applications
when you come to GCPN.
We've really done a lot of--
we've been working very hard.
We have a lot of interesting
new concepts to share with you.
So we're going to take a
holistic approach about how
to think about the security
and access control,
securing your data when
you're coming to Google Cloud
Platform.
My name is Ines
Envid by the way.
I'm a product manager
in Cloud, and I'll
be sharing the stage with Samrat
who's another project manager.
We'll have the pleasure
to have here Two Sigma,
who is a customer
who'll be sharing
their journey to the cloud and
how they use Google security.
And then we will
have finally, a walk
through partnerships
and the ecosystem
that we're building as well.
So with that, let's get started.
How are we thinking about
Google Cloud Platform
Security and your deployment.
So when you move your
deployments to the cloud,
then it is important
that you are
able to maintain your same
security posture that you
have today for your deployment.
But then when it comes
to the implementation,
the setup of policies, the
enforcement of those, it
really--
it really requires a little
bit of change of mindset.
The reason is that there
are a lot of different type
of deployments.
There are infrastructure
as a service,
for example with VM instances.
There can be as
well Google Cloud--
Google Kubernetes deployments.
There could be as well Google
Managed Services; for example,
storage or BigQuery,
and it is important
that we provide a holistic
approach for security
for all of them.
So for example, if you take a
storage, Google Cloud Storage,
it is really the access
to the data through APIs.
That means that,
and those services
are really managed by Google.
So that means that when
you're applying securities
you will need to control the
policies in a different way.
Because it needs to be
based on really attributes
and conditions that are
extracted from those API
calls so that you can restrict
the access, for example,
to data from specific sources.
And you can as well
have the ability
to restrict exfiltration.
So that for example API calls
cannot really take the data
outside to destinations
that not trusted by you.
How are we looking
at the framework
for setting up policies?
So leveraging on our
very vast infrastructure,
we recommend that you
are setting up policies
first on the edge.
So that meaning the edge
is like if you explicitly
announce in public apps,
for example load balancers,
you can set up those
policies that we are going
to enforce in our frontends.
And we have a large
infrastructure
to mitigate attacks and
I'll talk a little bit more
about that.
And then from there
you go to the core,
where they inputs
are hosted in cloud.
Another-- another
concept that I will
be talking in the
framework is we
are enabled to
set up of policies
that can be centralized managed,
but also they're context aware.
So meaning that when you
are setting up your policies
it is not only networking
construct that you can use,
but also identities,
the resources,
the projects in which you
would access in the data.
So let's walk through
that framework.
So how do you think about
setting up the access control
to your resources?
So first if you're exposing
public facing applications,
you should be
considering setting up
the policies with Cloud
Armor to expose those.
Clouds Armor, you can think of
it as web application firewall.
It applies to HTTPS,
HTTPS load balancers.
It's also a place to TCP,
SSL proxy load balancers,
and then it can
actually mitigate
attacks at the application
layer, or at L3 or L4
at the edge.
And we really are enforcing
those policies in our frontends
which are distributed
around the globe.
Now as you are going into
your private deployments,
you may want to
think of setting up
a perimeter in
which you consider
your deployments trusted.
And we are allowing
that perimeter
to be set up for both VM
deployments, Kubernetes engine
deployments, and also for
Google Managed Services.
And this is really what
we will be spending
a lot of time talking
about, how we were actually
thinking of building a
perimeter for accessing data
to those managed services.
Finally, you have the capability
to apply fine-grain policies
where there are application
specific conditions that
need to be applied
in the communication
within that perimeter
so that you can actually
have a micro segmentation
of how your application
and your services
talk with each other.
So let's walk through
everything together.
Again first, think about
how you're protecting
your public applications.
And then we have a load
balancer with Cloud Armor.
And that integrates with
Identity-Aware Proxy
so that as well, you can set up
your conditions so if would you
allow or deny based on the
identity of the user that
is trying to access those
public facing applications.
Second, if you want to
build kind of a macro
so in which you are considered
trusted your services,
you can use for GCVM
VPC level firewalls.
You can use if it's Google
Managed Services like a storage
in BigQuery, VPC
service control which
expands the concept for
these managed services.
And we'll talk a
little bit more later.
And if you're looking
at micro-segmentation,
then you can apply firewalls
based on service account, which
identify the applications that
are set up within that VPC.
You can use network policies
for your Google Kubernetes
deployments.
And you can as well use IAM for
more fine-grained conditions
for who's accessing the data for
your Google Managed services.
So starting from the edge
to the micro segmentation.
Now, Cloud Armor allows you
to set up your rules language.
It is a pretty
rich rules language
which allows you to set up
conditions based on application
level, but also L3 L4.
So you have a lot of
flexibility to build your rules.
There are also some--
some policies and rules
that are pretty common
so that you can just consume
them for specific patterns.
When you are now connecting
your trusted applications,
if you have either
VM instances or you
have Kubernetes clusters,
you can set up VPC firewalls
so that you can set
up your perimeter.
You can extend that securely
to your on-premises as well.
Now this is what we want
to share here specifically
with you today.
Now we are allowing
as well to have
that concept of service
perimeter for the Google
Managed Services.
What that means is
that if you are hosted
data in storage buckets,
in BigQuery data sets,
you are setting up--
You can set up
policies which are
able to express that only
the access of this data
within that perimeter, which
can be extended to on-premises,
is going to allow to
access those buckets.
So we'd actually check in source
control not only the identity--
the token identity
of the user, but we
are matching the app with a
source from which that user is
accessing that data.
Similarly, we are
also checking when
there is an egress action,
for example to write data.
That data it is not being
sent to a destination which
is outside that perimeter.
And then finally, we have
our fine-grained control.
Yes quickly, there is
a micro-segmentation,
a set of policies,
using service account.
This very convenient
service account
is the identity of your user
You can set up firewall rules
using that the
identity of the user
to set up policy
across those services.
You can use network policies
to set up the communication
control for your containers
input is based on name spaces.
So you can control
which namespace
is connected which ones.
And you can house as well IAM
for setting up more control
grain identity access control
to a specific resource
in, for example, buckets
or data set in BigQuery.
And with that, I really want
to spend some time explaining
how we're thinking about
providing that capabilities
for avoiding exfiltration
of your data,
building that
perimeter for your--
for the data that hosting
either in storage,
BigQuery or any of
our managed services.
I'm going to
welcome on the stage
Samrat Ray who's the product
manager for VPC Service
Controls and he's going
to explain how this works.
SAMRAT RAY: Thank you Ines.
So as Ines mentioned
and she explained,
the concepts and
principles of security
that you have been utilizing
on premise don't change.
But the application of those
concepts and principles
when you come to Cloud, you
have to optimize them for Cloud.
And one of the areas which
is very different on Cloud
from your on-premise is
that of managed services.
So we are going to dive a little
deeper into that specific area
since the application
is different from how
you are typically used to with
sort of L3 or L4 constructs
that you use to create
perimeters on prem.
So VPC service controls
they effectively it
extends your perimeter
security paradigm
into fully managed
services, services
that are exposed by APIs.
Those where the
resources themselves
don't have distinct
L3 identities, right?
They don't have distinct
IP addresses which you can
safeguard behind a firewall.
In doing so, by providing
a perimeter security,
it helps to mitigate
data exfiltration risks.
You can also use this
perimeter as a way
to privately access
your data from VPC,
but also from on-premise.
And I think as Ines
mentioned, if you
do want to grant access
from the internet,
you can use context awareness
to determine the level of trust
in a very application-centric
manner versus just the fact
that you are within
the network, right?
So you can use other
artifacts to grant access.
And finally, this
is really a tool
for organizational
administrators.
So one of the
challenges with IAM
traditionally has
been across all public
clouds is their
delegation model,
because IAM tends to be fine
grained policy management.
A lot of times IAM admins
or IAM administration itself
of the policies tend
to get delegated.
And then you have to do things
like monitor for compliance,
et cetera, which can be painful.
We have purposely designed this
to be a very macro clustering
posture that you can implement,
which the IAM administrators
cannot override.
So its a great way to
implement your sort
of mandatory minimum
security controls, right?
And then you can have further
fine-grained, application
specific controls
defined through IAM.
So we talked about
data exfiltration.
So it's important to understand
how can data exfiltration occur
from managed
services, and why that
is an issue on public clouds.
So typically what
would happen is
that your standard firewalls,
say your VPC network firewall,
you'd set a policy like
allow all access to GCS.
So it would be like
storage.google.googleapis.com
for example, right.
What that means is,
you can not only
access your own buckets
you can pretty much access
any buckets, right?
Because your firewall is
not aware of the resource
model of GCS up on cloud, or
BigQuery, or for that matter
any of the services that
you are consuming that
are fully managed.
So that leads to certain
risks that you are exposed to.
The first is that
your IAM become
sort of a single point of
failure for your security.
So you have-- if you have
misconfigured IAM policies,
and they may be intentional
or for malicious reasons,
or just for convenience
reasons, right,
you end up accidentally
exposing data.
And this has been fairly--
its been in the
news a lot, right?
Like this particular S3 bucket
or something that got exposed.
And its fundamentally a
lot of that, if you go
back and look at the
cause, its the first one.
But then that's
not the only thing.
You can have somebody
stealing identities.
And phishing and
stolen identities
are fairly common, right?
We talk elsewhere about how to
prevent your identities being
stolen using UB keys and
our phishing capabilities.
But nevertheless, you
still want to assume
that an entity has been phished
or the token has been stolen.
In which case, somebody
could access the data
from the internet
pretty much, and then
drop it-- push it
to Dropbox, right?
And that's an exfiltration.
The third is you actually
have an insider who,
and this is one of the
more difficult things
to control for.
So here you can just
mitigate the risk
versus eliminate the risk
in this particular case.
But you can mitigate
it significantly.
Is they are either
using compromised code
running in a VM or directly
accessing the bucket themselves
and running as simple as
a GCS dot copy command.
That's all you need right,
to move pretty much terabytes
of data from
buckets that you own
to public buckets
or buckets that
belong to the attacker, right?
So these are the paths
that we have shown here,
which are exposed to the risk.
So effectively what VPC
service controls does, is
it creates a virtual
perimeter around the resources
of your managed services
like GCS buckets or BigQuery
datasets, and it then
also maps the perimeter
to one or more VPC networks.
So you can simply add
your host project value,
if your PC network is defined,
into the virtual service
parameter.
And therefore, all
VMs in that network
then have access to the
resources within the perimeter,
within the service perimeter.
But the VMs don't have
access to resources
that are outside the perimeter.
So even if you read
the data into a VM,
you cannot write the data
to a resource that's outside
the perimeter.
Further, your service to service
communications, like copy calls
from say from GCS copy
call example that I gave,
or BigQuery trying to
query a GCS bucket.
These kind of pathways are also
controlled by this perimeter.
So what it does for
you, is it allows
you to effectively
take your data that's
sitting in a fully
managed service
and make it private, right?
And it provides in that sense
an ingress control, right?
Controls accessed
from the internet.
So access from the internet
is denied by default.
And egress controls.
So you prevent the
copying of data
outside to
unauthorized projects.
Ines did cover this, so I'll
go through this fairly quickly.
You can extend the security
posture to your on-prem
if you're connected to a
VPN or private interconnect.
You're on-prem
machines also will not
be able to-- if
you connect over--
if you use this technology and
you access our data privately,
you will also not be able
to, even from on-premise,
not be able to access
unauthorized GCS resources
or buckets.
So your exfiltration control
is propagated all the way
to on-premise.
And lastly, if you do
want to open up access,
you can do things like only
allow access from an IP range.
That's sort of the
LT environment.
But you can do something more
sophisticated like I would only
allow access from a
managed device given
you know UB key touch, and
so on and so forth, right.
So that gives you
the full the context
of our access to the parameter.
With that, I'll show
you how you can easily
define these policies and
manage them centrally at scale.
Demo please.
Great.
So this product is under
a private beta right now.
So if you're white listed
at this point in time,
or if you wait for us to
be in the public beta,
in one of those cases you would
see a couple of menu items.
One that says VPC
service controls.
The other says access
context manager.
So access context
manager is the tool
that allows you to define
these sort of access levels
that gives you
context of our access.
But today we'll do a
quick demo of VPC service
controls, the core
product that allows
you to build a perimeter.
So in this world, what
we're going to have is--
I'm going to show you
while starting up,
I'll start building
a new perimeter,
and I'll show you the structure
of the projects that exist.
So let's just call
it prod perimeter.
And let's look at the projects.
So in the projects, I'm just
go to filter it by over here
so we can narrow down
to the projects that
are relevant to this demo.
So I've get an attacker
project to represent
the unauthorized project
that has GCS bucket in it.
We also have a
compute VM, which I'm
going to use to explain
how I'm accessing data
from within the network,
for example, right?
And a storage project that
actually has the bucket
containing PII, right?
So before I create
the perimeter,
I just wanted to show you a
quick exfiltration batch here.
I hope you can hear me
when I keep the mic down.
Sorry about that.
There you go.
So the one I have got in my left
hand side menu is on my laptop.
So think of it as applying the
connects from the Internet,
right?
On the right is I have
actually association
to the VM that is inside the
production network, right?
So I'm going to
first demonstrate
that this is my bucket that
is actually in a production
bucket, WPSE secure bucket.
And I am able to access
it from my laptop, which
is from the internet,
and I'm also
able to access it from my
production my environment.
And I can then--
I have my attacker
bucket which obviously I
should be able to also be able
to access from the internet,
right?
It got new data in it.
And here's the
issue which we have,
which is you can also access
it from the production
environment, right?
So here's the exfiltration
but it's very complicated
as you will see.
It's the CB command that I run
over here from a production
environment, and I'm done.
And now, let's look
at the attacker bucket
from the Internet.
There you go.
My PIIs out on the Internet.
That's all I needed to do.
And it's available now
with no IAM permissions,
because the attacker
bucket is a public bucket.
So your data is now exposed to
the Internet but just this one
CP command.
Now this is-- because
it's so simple you
do want to mitigate this risk.
And the way we
mitigate this risk--
I'm going to quickly
delete the data for--
sorry I just deleted the data
for now from the record bucket.
But now we'll set up
the actual perimeter.
So we are now going to add
the projects, which I just
showed you except for
the attacker buckets.
We will add the
other buckets into--
all the other projects into a
service perimeter which I've
called prod perimeter here.
So we'll say add all
of three projects.
So as you can see I don't
have to do anything GCS
specific, or BigQuery specific.
This is one of the
powers of this control
is that it allows you to have
a very homogeneous way of doing
this across different
service types.
Now, I say which services
do I want to protect here.
Let's say I want to
protect the GCS API,
or the cloud storage
API and the big table
API because those are the
services that I care about.
So I'm going to
protect those too.
I don't use an access level.
When I don't use an
access level, that
means there's no access
from the Internet i.e.,
the data is private.
So let's do that.
Let's save it.
And there you go.
It's now-- it's created a
prod perimeter as you can see.
And it has the two
projects in there
and the two services
that it's protecting.
So let's go back sometimes
it takes a little time
to roll out the
configuration because there's
a global configuration.
But let's give it a quick
try to see if it's in place.
So now let's run the
copy command again
and let's see what happens.
The access was denied because
you could no longer exfiltrate
the data.
And similarly, if you tried to
now access the private bucket
from the internet,
right, you will
be denied access to the
private bucket from there.
So now you have
segmented your access.
Your internet facing client
can access the attacker bucket
but not the secure bucket.
And your production system
can access the secure bucket
but not the attacker, right?
So it's now fully segmented
and your exfiltration parts
have been closed up, right?
You can then grant access pretty
simply using access context
manager if you wanted to grant
access from the Internet,
so you can define
different access levels.
And then, when you go back to
your service controls page,
you can go back
to your perimeter
and you can simply decide
which access level do
you want to use to grant access
to resources in the service
perimeter, right?
So for example, I
could choose something
like high trust and [INAUDIBLE].
That means only clients that
are within this definition
of high trust, which
is in this IP range,
are allowed to access the data.
That's it, thank you.
Can we go back to
the slides please.
And with that I would like to
invite on stage our colleagues
from--
our customers Two
Sigma to talk about how
they have used this to mitigate
their exfiltration risk
in a real world deployment.
[APPLAUSE]
TONY WALKER: Hi, guys.
So my name's Tony Walker,
and I work for Two Sigma.
So to give you a
quick elevator pitch,
Two Sigma is an
investment manager
that uses a mixture of
data, science and technology
to derive insights into the
future that help us uncover
value in markets worldwide.
To give you some more
interesting information,
we currently have around
35 petabytes of data
that we store.
We collect that data
from over 10,000 sources.
And in terms of our
compute footprint,
we have about 95,000 cores and
somewhere around 1.8 terabytes
of memory.
I work in a public
cloud engineering group.
So our group is
focused on finding
ways in which we can
leverage the capabilities
of public cloud providers,
like Google, to improve
the productivity of
our engineering teams.
NICHOLAS ARVANITIS:
Thanks, Tony.
My name is Nick.
I work in security.
My team is a partner
team to Tony's team,
and we work very
closely together
on focusing on public
cloud platform security.
A lot of what Samrat and
Ines had talked about we
use pretty extensively.
If you think about our
business in the terms
that Tony described it,
one of our key assets
really is our IP.
And protecting our IP
is really crucial to us.
So when we think about threat
models and security controls,
really we're very
focused on trying
to mitigate data exfiltration.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about how we used--
we have a full set of
controls, but specifically
about VPC service
controls, and how
we use that in a real use
case for our business.
So we had a use case where we
had a research team who wanted
to work on massive data sets.
So part of our business is
dealing with external vendor
data sets, and often these
are huge, multiple terabytes.
We had a team who trialed
BigQuery and loved it
and wanted to really roll this
out to production use case.
So in order for
us to enable this,
we had a couple
of considerations.
And we try to get an
MVP up and running
to get this team going
as quickly as possible,
but we did have to make
a number of concessions
in order to have our
security constraints met.
And what you see
up on the screen
is a very simplified diagram.
We had-- We've
hand-waved a little
what the vendor
data pipeline is,
but we had a way that data
could get into a GCP project.
And we'd created
this GCP project
as a standalone environment
that was not directly connected
to our internal network.
So we were accessing this
over our internet proxies
from inside of Two Sigma.
And what we had to
do then is a lot
of extensive research developing
IAM roles that were really
essentially read-only.
There was a moving target.
So there was a lot of complexity
there, and a lot of tech debt
we racked up.
But what we eventually
ended up going with
was creating home servers
in the GCP project
that were GCP instances,
with services accounts bound
to them.
And the role that the
service account had
gave our researchers
and engineers
the permissions they needed to
interact with BigQuery and GCS,
and other core services.
The way they accessed those,
also from within Two Sigma,
also hand-waved a little is we
had a bastion type environment
where we were able
to restrict things
like copying and pasting, ACP,
but still give them shell level
access so that they could
then start to iterate.
One of the key
benefits here was they
were able to start to
work on those data sets
and process them
and create research.
And we were able to get them
up and running really quickly,
but there were quite a
few drawbacks as well
and I'll hand back to
Tony to talk about some
of the drawbacks.
TONY WALKER: Thanks, Nick.
Yes so as Nick said, this got
us up and running very quickly
but there were some downsides.
So we start with
the home server.
This was a real
disconnect for our users.
Nick mentioned the
bastion access.
So this added additional hop.
A lot of the researchers
wanted to use tools
that they were used to using
home servers, inside Two Sigma.
But to actually get out
and play with the data
in a read-write manner they had
to go out onto the home servers
to do this.
This also, as Nick
mentioned, the
added complexity that we had
to deal with two different IAM
identities.
We had to have a Two Sigma
user that was read only,
and an external
identity that gave them
the full read-write access.
Another big problem
was the fact that this
was connected over the
Internet and went by proxy.
So often one of the
common use cases
the researchers would
have is that they
would want to join the local Two
Sigma data with data that they
had from the vendors.
And there was no
good way form them
to do this because essentially
this was exfiltration.
So what they end up having
to do was raise a gira.
They would put in a request.
Their manager would
have to prove it.
And then it would go
to Nick and his team,
and they would then have
to jump onto a secure site
and push the data up.
And we're talking terabytes of
data, multiple times a week.
We ended up having to coalesce
those requests to once a week.
And as you can imagine,
this was a real problem
for trying to remain
agile for our teams.
Uploading was one problem.
Downloading was also
another problem.
So the corporate
proxies we use these
to ensure that our security
perimeter is kept well
put together for users
for Internet access.
But when we had the
research teams wanting
to download terabytes of
data at the same time,
we would often find that
they have either performance
problems or actual
terminated jobs.
And also other
engineering groups
completely, independent
from them in Two Sigma,
were suffering as well.
So these were some
real problems.
And Nick's going
to talk about now
about what we did to fix that.
NICHOLAS ARVANITIS: Thank you.
Being a design
partner with Google,
yeah we didn't want
to develop solutions
that were less than optimal or
would rack up even more tech
debt on our side.
So we decided to
reach out to Google,
and we engaged with the
network services team, Samrat
and Ines' team.
We talked about our requirements
and what our considerations
were, and also what
our security model was,
and some of the threats
we wanted to mitigate.
And serendipitously it worked
out that at the same time
they were starting to
develop the concept of what
is now VPC service controls.
So we spent a lot of
time in design sessions
with the product and
engineering teams,
kind of understanding
what the roadmap was, sort
of communicating what
our considerations were.
And then were really
early adopters.
We obviously did our
validation testing, our
of form penetration testing.
And then were able to create
an environment that was
Version 2 of what we have here.
But we tried to solve
some of the problems
that Tony had highlighted.
So up there, I'm
going to let Tony
go into more detail
about some of the steps
that we took to address kind of
and some of those shortcomings.
TONY WALKER: Thanks, Nick.
So yeah as you see, the
diagram that's up here
is very similar to what we
had before with two really
key differences.
So one, the GCP project is now
in its own secure perimeter.
And two, the project
is directly connected
to Two Sigma via Private
Cloud Interconnect.
Now this was-- this introduced
major benefits for us.
First of all, users
could now safely
use all of the native services
directly from inside Two Sigma
from their home servers.
We didn't have to maintain
these dual identities for them.
So the IAM complexity
that I mentioned before
was essentially removed.
Additionally now that
we're going directly
over the private interconnect,
the upload and download problem
disappeared.
You just could push
data with impunity
because there was no
exfiltration risk.
And they could
download over a pipe
which was much, much
bigger than what
we were delivering via our
standard Internet access.
Similar are some side benefits.
By removing the need for these
bastion and home servers,
we actually reduced
the infrastructure
that had to remain in the
project, so actually saved
ourselves some money as well.
So ultimately, this resulted
in a major velocity jump
for the group that was
doing the research.
And we quickly
realized that this
was going to be something
that would be very
popular throughout the company.
So what we wanted to do was
to try and standardize this
into a general platform that
we could roll out to anyone.
Now before we did this,
there was one technical thing
we had to overcome,
and that is that to use
the secure perimeter access,
the perimeter project
has to advertise a route
back to your internal network
over which you can
access all the APIs.
And this was fine for doing
this with a proof of concept
that we had here, but as you can
imagine if we were doing this
for potentially hundreds
of these projects
we needed to find a way
that we could scale that.
And Nick's going to talk
a bit more about that now
NICHOLAS ARVANITIS: Thank you.
Again we didn't want to
engineer something ourselves,
so to a man with a hammer,
everything looks like a nail.
We'd had success previously
working with the Google team,
so we decided to
reach back out again
and explain what our
new situation was.
And in this case,
again, it turned out
that it was timely because
Google was thinking
about the concept
of how to bridge
multiple secure
perimeters together.
At the time there was a product
or feature of VPC service
controls called Zone Bridges.
And really this led us to a
platform that you see now.
At a very high level,
what zone bridges are is
you can take two
individual perimeters
and you can create a
bridge between them
such that the APIs can
be securely accessed
from each individual project.
So you can define, essentially
multiple different parameters.
And when you need
them to interconnect
you can have them
interconnect, or you can
keep them completely distinct.
So how we built this into an
architecture that really worked
out for us was we
defined a single
what we called like a
gateway project for GCP.
And really what the role
of that was, was twofold.
The first role was to advertise
that route back to Two Sigma
that Tony was just talking
about to access a secure APIs.
So that was our path into
access to the secure perimeters.
The other thing
that it did was also
represent our internal
network and internal systems
itself as a source
secure perimeter,
so that we could then
bridge that perimeter
with other parameters that
we wanted to ground access to
and enable access to
native Google services
from within Two Sigma
in a secure fashion.
So this really allowed us to
scale horizontally and create
multiple different use
cases instead of having
just that single project.
There was one more
technical challenge
we had to deal with though.
And this is maybe
diving a little deeper.
Again, we've kind
of hand-waved again
how we got data, vendor data
securely into the project.
If you want to learn
more about that
we can talk about it afterwards.
But it's fairly complex.
But the other challenge besides
that we had to deal with
was when you access the
secure API endpoint,
it actually lives on
a different endpoint.
The endpoint is
restricted.googleapis.com.
So you needed a
mechanism by which
you could remap any of the calls
like for example, Google Cloud
Storage is normally storage.
So googleapis.com.
You needed a mechanism
to remap that
to restricted.googleapis.com
for your clients.
At the time,
Google's private DNS
didn't exist for us inside the
VPC so we couldn't use that.
And we also needed a solution
for our internal network.
So again, we went and
did some research.
This time we didn't
trouble Google with this.
We solved this one ourselves.
But we learned that within
our own internal DNS
infrastructure, there was
a mechanism for this called
response policy zones.
So RPZ is what it's known as.
We implemented that
and we were good to go.
Any requests for
Google APIs we're now
hitting the restricted endpoints
and our users are good.
TONY WALKER: So
in conclusion this
was a real game changer for us.
Having private
access to the APIs
directly from our
own internal network
enabled researchers
to get up and running,
and access to the native
tools that we ultimately want
to roll out across other teams.
And unsurprisingly,
after we did this,
we found many
internal teams were
coming to us wanting to make
use of what this capability gave
them.
And we expect this to
continue as Google rolls out
more and more services
into VPC service controls.
So if you're interested,
as Nick said,
if you're interested
in hearing anything
more about this
at a deeper level,
come talk to us afterwards.
We'll be outside.
And if you think any of
it sounds interesting,
we're hiring.
NICHOLAS ARVANITIS:
So with that,
will hand over to Vineet to
talk about Google's partner
ecosystem.
VINEET BHAN: Thank you.
So you guys heard a
lot of great stuff
that our Google
has been building.
The key security concept and
features that you can use.
In addition to
what Google builds,
there are partners, security
companies, that all of you
have been working
for years and years.
We also work closely with
those security companies
to make sure their
solutions can complement
what Google can do so you can
seamlessly use those products.
So I will look over how we
are working with partners
and how they
complement what Google
does in terms of security.
So the most important
concept to understand first
is the shared security model,
I wanted to re-emphasize that
at the start.
So security at the core
infrastructure level
will be something that
Google will provide for you
at the infrastructure level.
But for your services,
your projects,
you have to think about
how you would secure it.
Leveraging the technology that
Google is building and layering
on partner products
on top of that.
So you have to
think about clearly
in terms of what things
are covered by Google
at the infrastructure level.
What is your responsibility
and how do you
cover that and have a
security policy to do that.
So there are a lot of Google
products as I mentioned.
There are also partner
products that complement.
This is an I-chart.
I wouldn't cover all the boxes.
But there are a couple
of areas or categories
that I would emphasize.
For example, the next-gen
firewall category.
They have been around
for a long time.
Most companies use them.
Its a kind of category
of products that
complement to what Google do.
And you know we can think
of hardware security
module as an example
of another category
that companies use especially
in the banking sector.
So you can use those
products in addition
to what Google provides natively
to meet different requirements
that you have.
It could be regulatory
requirements.
Could be you're comfortable
using a product from a partner
and you want to
continue and extend
that product into
your GCP deployments,
you can absolutely do that.
So think about how you kind of
layer on the partner products
with what Google provides.
So other just kind of sharing
kind of the ecosystem we
have with partners.
Over the last one
year we have grown it
4x in terms of
security companies.
So a huge increase
in terms of security,
leading names in security
who have solutions.
A broad category of
partners so and pretty much
all the big names in security
that you can think of.
Any product that you use in
security works with GCP now.
So you can think
about which categories
are relevant in your business,
which products you're
comfortable using and
you can absolutely
go use those products.
And most of these products
are listed on the Google GCP
marketplace.
So you can look at the
market based products
that are available or
work with the partners
and ask them know how
do they support GCP.
So I will just not go
through all the categories.
I will just double click
on a few categories that
are very important,
especially for folks
who are you're new to GCP.
So with the next-gen firewalls
that I mentioned before.
App level of visibility, the
hybrid connectivity from cloud,
to your on-prem deployments,
are very common use cases
that we see.
Pretty much you know all major
next-generation firewalls
are supported on GCP.
And it's not only
supporting them
and having their firewall
run as a VM in GCP,
we're working very closely
with leading security companies
to build next generation
of security solutions.
So are not just match what
used to happen on-prem,
but how do we make
security better
by working with
security companies.
How do we do it in a
more scalable fashion,
more automatable fashion.
So a lot of interesting stuff
a lot of interesting innovation
happening with these partners.
And one key concept
is that works
very well with these
next-gen firewalls
is a shared VPC concept.
So if you guys
haven't looked at it,
it's a very seamless way
of routing all your traffic
to next-gen firewall, having
controls at the host project
level.
And the service
projects will be routed,
all the traffic will be
routed to your host project.
So it's a very
unique Google feature
that works very well
with a next-gen firewall.
I had been talking to
customers and partners,
and the comments I got
was this is closest
we have seen to
getting the controls we
used to have on-prem and in
a public cloud environment.
So if you haven't looked at
it, please do look at it.
It's a very strong
and useful feature.
So next category I want to talk
about was application security.
So as you think about
how do I protect
against application
level DDoS attacks,
WAIF kind of functionality.
Ines mentioned
about Cloud Armor.
So we have lot of
flexibility in this category.
As an example, you could use
Cloud Armor, the native rules
that we have on Cloud Armor.
You could have partner rules
that partners are generating
and ingest them
into Cloud Armor.
You could have a DNS based WAIF
or DNS based application DDoS
protection solution.
So you don't deploy anything.
It's deployed outside
of Google Cloud,
or you could use a
VM based solution.
So there are a lot
of flexibility,
a lot of options available.
Depending on your requirements
or your preferences,
you can pick any of the
options that are available.
So next category that's
kind of very unique to cloud
is the compliance in
the Cloud category.
These are Cloud
native solutions.
Companies like RedLock, Dome9
and others, that will help you.
Once you are deployed, you
want to get a quick check
on where do you stand in
terms of your PCI compliance.
So they can go in, do
a quick check and say,
hey you're compliant,
or these rules
need to be changed to make
you more PCI compliant.
So this makes your
life much easier.
So if you compare
this with on-prem role
where everything had to be
done you know largely manually,
these are the kind of
partners who can bring in
with just creating
a service account,
can generate reports
within minutes
to tell you where you are.
So this helps to get
you more compliant.
Another layer of checks
that you can layer in.
So other key concept
I wanted to share
was in the Cloud
Security Command Center
is a great tool that
Google has built
that you guys may have seen
some of the sessions regarding
Cloud Security Command Center.
But this is one place where all
the thread data, all the kind
of visibility of what services,
what kind of resources
you are using.
And you can consolidate
all the thread data,
all the analysis Google runs on
security in the command center,
and also at partner
products on top of that.
So this will be your
one place in GCP
where you can get all
the Google signals,
you will get all
the partner signals
to see in one dashboard
what's going on.
So this is a great innovation.
It simplifies your life.
So one place to get
a security poster.
And we're working
closely with companies
to kind of take it to
the next level as well.
So once you have
the visibility, how
do you make it easier for you
to kind of react with the data
that you have.
With that, I would
like to close on
with just rehashing I think what
we discussed in this session.
I think about when you're
thinking about security as Ines
mentioned, think about
security you know right
from the perimeter and from your
edge, to code off your network.
And when you're
creating security rules,
think of security
rules from coarse grain
to fine grain security rules.
The service controls are
kind of great addition.
They're providing
great capabilities
to get you to the next
level of security.
And think about layering
on partner solutions
of a big ecosystem
of partners that
provide great capabilities.
Think about leveraging
them as well.
Thank you.
Now I think time
for a few questions
if anybody has questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]